les ukrainiens sont un peu moins
nombreux à quitter leur pays mais le
nombre de réfugiés pourrait dépasser les
4 millions d'ici quelques jours c'est ce
que dit l'onu la plupart trouvent refuge
en pologne là où des milliers de
migrants avaient été refoulés souvenez
vous ces hommes ces femmes ces enfants
venus du moyen-orient avait été
instrumentalisé par la biélorussie alors
arrivée en europe il avait trouvé porte
close bonjour marlène panarabe êtes
journaliste pour le site info migrants
point net quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui à la frontière entre la
pologne et la biélorussie alors d'après
les ong sur place il y aurait
aujourd'hui entre 650 et 800 personnes
dans cette zone ce sont en majorité des
kurdes qui ont quitté l'irak mais il ya
aussi des exilés syriens des afghans des
iraniens et aussi quelques personnes du
congo kinshasa il y à beaucoup de
familles avec des enfants et aussi des
bébés tout son père toutes ces personnes
sont coincées dans les bois au milieu
des marais et comme depuis le début de
la crise en novembre elles sont refoulés
de chaque côté de la frontière par les
gardes-frontière polonais et biélorusses
ce que l'on constate aussi sec depuis
quelques semaines ces petits groupes
d'exilés sont plus nombreux qu'en
janvier où qu'en février pour quelles
raisons alors en fait tout début mars
les autorités biélorusses ont fermé le
centre d'accueil temporaire de brousse
guian en biélorussie à cette fermeture
les les gardes ont posé un ultimatum aux
occupants soit il repartait à minsk et
prenait un avion pour rentrer chez eux
soit il reparti dans l'autre sens à pied
direction la pologne c'est ce que la
plupart des occupants ont fait vous êtes
justement en contact avec certains de
ces exilés à travers le site info
migrants point net ils vous disent quoi
elle vous raconte quoi oui tout à fait
alors un faux migrants a pu parler à
mort scène c'est un jeune homme de 25
ans qui a quitté l'iran il ya deux mois
et demi aujourd'hui l'état kaleme mais
il y a quelques semaines lui aussi était
coincé dans les bois avec un petit
groupe de personnes ils sont tombés sur
les gardes-frontière polonais qui les
ont violenté qui les ont frappé
plusieurs minutes et un ami de mort
scène a même été
attrapé par un parent garde il
l'emmenait dans une camionnette il lui a
projeté du gaz lacrymogène directement
dans les yeux et puis les gardes
frontière ont continué à frapper ce
petit groupe en leur criant de retourner
en biélorussie et justement biélorussie
on constate aussi des violences oui ces
migrants en fait sont menacés dans toute
la zone frontalière une militante des
droits humains nous a raconté que un
jeune homme avait passé plusieurs jours
dans le no man's land et que pour se
libérer il avait coupé des fils barbelés
avec avec une pince cette personne a été
arrêté par les gardes mobiles aux russes
ils l'ont emmené et avec cette même
ainsi lyon ils ont sectionné en fait un
morceau de doigt voilà et puis ils ont
fini par le frapper aux reins et à la
tête ces scènes de violence elles sont
régulières et elles sont continus en
fait depuis le mois de novembre
d'ailleurs ce mot allah en novembre
infos migrants s'étaient déplacés en
pologne avait rencontré youssef un
syrien de 37 ans qui lui aussi avait été
violemment battu par les gardes
biélorusse et deux semaines après son
agression il avait encore des hématomes
partout sur le visage et sur le corps le
sort des migrants venus du moyen-orient
est moins connu que celui des ukrainiens
pour quelles raisons en fait il faut
savoir que depuis septembre la zone est
en état d'urgence donc ça c'est une
décision du parlement polonais qui a été
renouvelé plusieurs fois ce qui empêche
les médias d'enquêtés sur place et ce
qui complique aussi vraiment le travail
des ong
depuis le début de la crise c'était déjà
difficile de savoir ce qu'il s'y passait
mais la salle est encore plus avec
malheureusement le déclenchement de la
guerre en ukraine qui a totalement
éclipsé cette situation aujourd'hui
la lumière est braquée sur la frontière
polonaise avec l'ukraine donc plus au
sud du pays où les gardes frontières
accueille en fait à bras ouverts les
déplacés ukrainien c'est une situation
qui est dénoncée en pologne mais qui
aussi évidemment dénoncé dans d'autres
pays d'europe comme en france et c'est
un
deux poids deux mesures qui choque
autant les associations que les exilés
eux mêmes merci beaucoup pour ces
précisions marlène panard et toutes ces
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site info migrants point net